this is um the last question in the
MultiChoice of lost news 83 okay now I'm
gonna uses an opportunity to try and
talk about areas beneath curves and
particularly when you're at these
negative areas and what they mean it has
an asteroid so let's just understand
this question first and then we'll talk
about the related ideas for the above
diagram it's known that if this is this
extreme it they give you this surface
result not to six G minus F with respect
to X is and then they tell you all the
rest of these information with the
maintenance okay
then they want you to work out well okay
what happens if I just want the integral
of G that's actually the question okay
let's just have a look at what's this
thing telling you you just tell you G -
f that's this parabola - the straight
line right now when you subtract one
function from another you don't just get
area beneath the curve you get the area
between two curves if you remember that
from when you first were introduced to
integration okay now people get spun out
of it because they think whoa away this
is confusing because this is there's a
negative area going on here okay so is
it still going to be the area between
the curves or does this thing you become
negative and then add back and it's
confusing in general okay so the way I
might even think about it is just
consider if we took the same two graphs
and then just ignore the whole negative
problem okay if I move them all up I
mean suppose this was the same graph but
moved it up five units okay
and suppose this was the same rap but
moved it up five digits so now this axis
is no longer in the way it's no longer
problem okay everything here is positive
now my first question to you is if I
move both of them up five units okay
what's the relationship between this
area between the two curves and this
area between the two curves if
if this is just this moved up five units
what's the difference between the two
areas there are there's no difference
right all I've changed the location okay
but it's still actually the same region
does that make sense now I kind of when
you look at this intuitively everyone
gets oh it's the top function if I
integrate that between from north to six
okay you degrade that and you'll get
this this whole area and then you want
to subtract this trapezium looking thing
okay so you get but it's G of X plus
five minus f of X was 5 and integrate
okay but because all I've done is move
both of them up by this constant right
not to six if I actually do this
computation G of X plus five minus f of
X all we do it doesn't take that much to
see the clusters it just cancel out
having moved this up or down whether
it's totally above the axis or kind of
above the axis or totally below the axis
if you do this like if I if my simple
let's move the whole thing down before
suppose I moved it down fifty units so
now the whole pot lot is now you know
your x-axis is somewhere up here okay
everything's negative but these 50s are
going to cancel it's still exactly the
same integral and exactly the same area
as it was before irrespective of
location cancel and you ended up back
here okay so that whole thing thing this
or thing also 30 okay
now therefore if we're trying to work
out well what's just the top part what's
the pump bounded by the parabola now
that's why this becomes relevant and
it's different to this question now okay
cuz then I'm thinking about just this
and I'm bound it to the axis now okay
I'm not valid to this curve wherever it
might be so now this question of this
question are different so how do I work
it out the difference is just that
triangle down the bottom there isn't it
this one
okay so to work out that triangle all
you have to do like you don't have to
form an integral for it you just have to
say base times height on - you can just
consider all as positive values and that
will give you an arrow 6 right yep
so that's going to be up here the 30
minus is which gives you 24 which I
think was big okay now I think God asked
the question was suppose you know this
wasn't once or twice an action to do
some setting up in that kind of thing
and I was asked to use an integral to
find the area of this triangle much of
wine because it's just a triangle but
suppose okay what kind of integral would
you form and actually this is this kind
of matters so there's a lot of different
fudgie sort of ways to do this I'm going
to show you the correct way and I'll
show you why I think it's more correctly
you can actually tell me what the
equation of f of X is not cheap look at
it it's well to find a straight line
let's do it in X plus take what's the
way in its 1/3 so you've got an X plus B
which is negative 2 in this case so
there's my equation okay so I'm going to
be forming an integral with that as the
integrand okay
now I'm from naught to 6 right because
I'm going from left to right this is a
function terms X so my variables want to
be in X as well so there's the integral
okay now when you give this a go well
that's just quickly integrated show me
what do ya what is your actual primitive
function
x squared on 6 - 2 X - 6 now you give
this a guard and you what to expect you
get a negative result right I mean based
on what the triangle is I'm expecting
negative 6
okay now here's the thing okay if you're
trying to work out an area and they tell
you you've got to use an integral okay
you kind of have two choices you can
slap an absolute value sign in the whole
log because you're like look I can see
it's all follow the axis okay and so I
can just say the area I'm really
interested in is this because it is
right this which is this which gives you
see at the end okay now some people will
do that in this case I think you're
gonna be okay but in a second I'll show
you why I think that's actually not such
a bad idea here's the way I prefer
absolute value you have to be super
careful about okay whenever you bring
them into play you have to justify them
very carefully and in that case I didn't
really just the final I just told you to
look at the diagram okay I think I'm
much safer way is just to stick with the
original integral get a negative and
then you can say as the area is below
the axis so that's accounting for the
fact that it's negative right
it is six units squared and I keep that
as a separate theme okay please please
please please do not get to this point
say uh-oh needs to be positive that our
is six okay then that's mathematically
that's kind of like because waiting is
come from it came from oh I've got the
wrong answer I better fix it right it
didn't come from any mathematical
justification
whereas this demonstrates understanding
all right this is I know what it means
when this is a menu and relates to this
right having these two separate premium
units here I think is a much
way to go now I said before it was
dangerous to just slap up to the values
over the top of every day okay
here's why let's consider let's do this
moving thing you're doing
suppose we take this graph and it's no
longer a 30 X minus 2 suppose it was a
30 X minus 1 oh yeah that's what you
look like roughly that should be three
should okay now if I repeat the question
and I say well tell me the area bounded
between this graph and for go to 6 and
the x-axis okay you can see what the
problem is you cannot simply whack an
absolute value sign in and get a value
out and then go home just to okay
because of course when you about it it's
in to rule you will get wicked 0 won't
you I'm sorry this matters to better see
the other guy zero zero will be okay but
that's not true right what's gone wrong
we formed the ball integral so if you're
asked for area you're gonna need to form
two integrals here right you're gonna
have to split it apart in some way okay
now you could do it this way you could
go okay I can do it from naught to three
I'll get a negative and then say well
that must be 3 and square I need it from
3 to 6 and I'll get 3 and then I had
them oh okay
alternatively I could break it into two
here I could say the absolute value of 0
to 3 plus okay and that will give you
the same area
but again you can see you have to be
careful it's like well why did you put
the absolute values here and not on this
one right you need to explain that in
some way which one I think this is a
safer way to go okay this is far more I
know it's gonna run down articulating it
okay in a picture in a hurry sure stop
the absolute value signs I'll get the
right answer at the end okay I think
this is a more articulate way to
standard does that make sense